supongamos que tenemos una reacción
elemental con un reactivo y que se
transforma en los productos y podemos
clasificar esta reacción de acuerdo a su
molecular y that es decir el número de
moléculas que participan en la reacción
en este caso tenemos una molécula dea
que se transforma en los productos así
que esta es una reacción un y molecular
sólo tenemos una molécula un y molecular
ahora escribamos la ley de velocidad
sabemos por los vídeos anteriores que la
velocidad de reacción es igual a la
constante k por la concentración de los
reactivos que en este caso es a
para este caso podemos tomar el
coeficiente de nuestra ecuación
balanceada y convertirlo en nuestro
exponente 1 esto sólo lo podemos hacer
para reacciones de un solo paso no
podemos hacerlo para una reacción
general como veremos en el siguiente
vídeo
entonces la velocidad de la reacción es
igual a la constante de velocidad k por
la concentración de a a la primera
potencia esta reacción
1 y molecular es de primer orden ahora
veamos la siguiente reacción una
molécula de a más una molécula debe
forma nuestros productos aquí tenemos
dos moléculas que participan en la
reacción así que es una reacción mi
molecular
y molecular entonces podemos pensar en
estas moléculas colisionando la molécula
a colisiona con la molécula de para
formar los productos y la ley de
velocidad dependerá de la concentración
de a&b si aumentamos la concentración de
a idv aumentamos la frecuencia de las
colisiones y por lo tanto aumenta la
velocidad de reacción
entonces la velocidad de reacción es
igual a la constante k por la
concentración de a y como es una
reacción elemental de un solo paso
podemos tomar el coeficiente y ponerlo
como exponente entonces por la
concentración de a a la primera potencia
por
la concentración debe nuevamente podemos
tomar el coeficiente que es 1 y ponerlo
como exponente esta es la ley de
velocidad para una reacción be molecular
ahora echemos un vistazo a otra reacción
be molecular
esta vez tenemos dos moléculas de a que
reaccionan para obtener nuestros
productos así que podemos decir que a
más a nos da productos objetos y nos dan
nuestros productos puede ser cualquiera
de las dos si nos quedamos con la
primera versión tenemos un coeficiente
aquí y uno acá así que al escribir la
ley de velocidad la velocidad es igual a
la constante de velocidad acá por la
concentración de a que tiene un
coeficiente de 1 así que está elevada a
la primera potencia
la concentración de la otra que también
tiene un coeficiente de 1 y lo ponemos
como exponente si factor izamos la
velocidad es igual a la constante k por
la concentración de a al cuadrado y si
escribimos la ley de velocidad con la
segunda opción el coeficiente 2 se
convierte en este exponente este es otro
ejemplo de una reacción be molecular
finalmente veamos una reacción en donde
participan tres moléculas una idea más
una debe más una de c nos dan nuestros
productos entonces cómo participan tres
moléculas esta es una reacción tri
molecular
y molecular
y esto puede ocurrir en un solo paso es
decir que si tenemos a b y c todos
tienen que colisionar al mismo tiempo
aunque no es muy común que eso pase por
eso las reacciones tri moleculares son
muy raras pero podemos escribir la ley
de velocidad la velocidad es igual a la
constante de velocidad k por la
concentración de a que tiene un
coeficiente de 1 así que está elevada a
la primera potencia por la concentración
de b que también está elevada a la
primera potencia
la concentración de cee también elevada
a la primera potencia entonces para la
ley de velocidad de estas reacciones
elementales podemos tomar el coeficiente
y convertirlo en el exponente en el
siguiente vídeo veremos que no podemos
hacer eso con una reacción de varios
pasos y que la velocidad de reacción
sólo se puede obtener experimentalmente